(upbeat music)
- I think you should stay there because
you have a very just clean look.
Your hair, your skin,
your height, your eyebrow.
Yeah, your bone structure.
- You have like an
overall like, model vibe.
- Yeah.
- I love the confidence
you all have in me.
I appreciate it.
I'm glad to stay here, but-
(all laugh)
- I agree with everybody,
but I think Jaelynn should be first.
(all mumble in agreement)
She is the stereotype of American beauty.
- Yeah, and I hate to say it,
but I feel like because she's a girl-
- Also because you're a woman.
- Because girls make more than men,
more than men in modeling usually.
- Okay. So we can switch.
- All right, sure, yeah.
- I think you need to move-
- I don't know,
- Need you up here too.
- Aw, thank you guys.
- The smile, the hair,
- Smile, yeah yeah, the height.
- You got the tattoos,
you could definitely
could book the fun but also edgy.
(all mumble in agreement)
- Yes.
My vote for sure. From
how you look for - Sure.
- And diversity, so that's-
- I feel like you also
though could be booking
a lot of beauty and hair campaigns.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Why don't you come next to me first?
- Yeah.
- And let's also-
- I'm gonna go this.
(mumbled discussion)
- I feel good.
- Are we good with this?
- I feel comfortable.
- Okay.
- Yeah. Alright.
- Alright.
(upbeat music)
- It's a Vulcan magazine.
- Okay.
- Beautiful.
- Wow.
- Oh my God.
- It was actually one of my first shoots
and to this day it's my
favorite photo shoot ever.
All right, you go ahead.
- Okay, so mine was a
campaign with Tommy Hilfiger.
(all ooh in excitement)
- Oh nice.
- This was an exciting moment for me,
seeing my photos like all over the store.
I was mad hype about that.
- Mine is this campaign with skins.
(all gasp)
- Okay, congratulations.
- Go off skin.
- First time in a bikini.
I don't even own one,
which is kind of weird.
It was kind of like uncomfortable for me.
But it was, it was great.
- So mine is a video.
- There's me.
- Verizon?
(excited chatter)
- Okay. Lines.
- That's what I'm talking about.
- For mine, was like an
American Eagle campaign.
It was overly shot in Mexico.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- Beautiful.
- I like that one.
- Mine is for Instagram and Facebook.
- Oh that's, that's amazing.
(excited chatter)
- That's fire!
- And this was on billboards everywhere.
- Oh my gosh.
- But I've been modeling
for like 10 years, so-
- Forever 21, which I did this year.
And it was like their full rebranding
that they did like, different.
- I saw this!
- Oh my!
(excited chatter)
- It's just really recognizable,
and also it was in Times Square.
So, it was like super fun.
- I love that.
- Okay.
- It does not make it any easier.
Because everybody's book, I was like, oh!
Where are you placed?
- I'm placed at Ford models
in LA, Miami, Chicago,
and New York with Wilhelmina
- LA I'm with Wilhelmina,
New York I'm with Society,
San Francisco I'm with
Three Model Management,
Chicago I'm with Option One.
My mother agent is IMD
and I'm also placed in
Miami with Wilhelmina.
- You should get in the back there.
- Yeah, let's switch already.
(excited discussion)
- Wait, what? You got stuff too?
What you mean, why?
(all laughing)
- I'll also say based on the campaign-
- Based off of that, yeah.
- Like the Tommy Hilfiger
and like it being in stores
is like a print option.
Like there's a lot of money.
- That's big, big money.
- Yeah, that's big money.
- Okay. I'm actually not signed and I,
you know, network like crazy.
- Yeah.
- I don't even think I'm
supposed to be here, low key.
- That's hard.
- But I'm here so we're, you know.
- So I have my mother agent
is NTA and that's all.
That's all who I'm
represented by, so, that's it.
- I'm with Wilhelmina
LA, New York, Next Miami,
MGM Germany, I Love Milan.
We have the same mother
agency in IMD, Shadow IMD and-
- You need to move that way.
- I feel like, I feel
and working in Mexico
- Maybe right now and in Mexico.
- Oh my God.
- I feel like you should
go in front of me.
- The travel.
- Yeah, travel is like-
Yeah, the travel again.
- Next to him for sure.
- I'm signed with right now Wildflowers.
It's a commercial agency.
- I feel like you should move
up because your ad was so cool
and you said you've been
doing this for 10 years.
- Yeah, that's true.
So I feel like you're like, know the game.
Everyone agree with that?
- I agree.
- I'll concur with this sentiment.
- I think this is good depending on-
- Well, since you're not rep'd,
I feel like you should-
- I should be last.
- Second to last.
- Second to last, okay.
- I don't know.
How many ads have you done?
- Yeah.
- This year? 20.
- Okay, you need to come up here.
- I kind feel like you should be up here.
- Yeah you've done 20
ads are the big money.
- The ad that you just did
was highly recognizable.
Your face in the Forever 21 campaign.
Yeah. Yeah you should.
- I think you should get in front of me.
(upbeat music)
(whispered discussion)
(camera shutter clicking)
- Y'all are funny.
(all laughing)
(camera shutter clicking)
- Whoa!
- Erm, this is about the pants.
- Pants.
(camera shutter clicking)
Oh, oh okay.
Oh, chic.
- I try my best to not think about
what I think I look like
because that's how you get very nervous.
So I just imagined what, like,
I'm trying to present to the camera.
- I'm gonna do some, some commercial.
Be like, "hey yo, what's up?
I love you.
You're so, oh my God,
this phone is crazy."
Like, oh wait, why am I doing this?
This is the kind of phone we have now.
I don't know, I was just like, because I,
I don't take myself
seriously so I was like,
this is what I do mostly.
And it's so silly and it's so cringe.
But I was like, at least I
can show something different
than what everybody else is doing.
- Mine's really easy but I don't think any
of you can probably do it.
(all cheering)
- Like, I always have my hands in my hair
and then we like flip
it, grab it, you know.
And then we do this
back one where we like,
look back at it while grabbing the hair.
- So for me, I like to
go close to the camera.
I kind of wanna, I kind
of like to do this.
(all ooh)
I always like to show my shape.
- Okay, yeah.
- Like this and sometimes
it's just my face right here.
This, this.
And my hair too, it's always straight.
So I'm always like flipping it, like this.
- Yes.
- It's always up in the air.
Holy shit.
Did I know how to pose?
Absolutely not.
I just worked with what
I had and just did it.
- Anyone's mind change about the ranking.
- I personally, after
that I would still say
that I think that you're second.
- Those poses were-
- Yeah, that's a solid.
(excited chatter)
- I think she should be number one.
- I think you should be number one.
- Wow.
- These be clients, you hear that guys.
- I'm gonna hang out right here.
- I'm home!
- But like she's so cool, and I was like-
- Gabby, I feel like you
should maybe go back one.
- Yeah. I expected this.
- It's the wheely.
- I was thinking Monica,
'cause we were all, like-
- You said your hair is normally curly.
- You're probably booking so
much with hair and beauty.
- That's what I'm saying, like.
- That's what I'm saying, like it's,
especially if it's like your go-to.
Like it has to be.
- Yeah
- I'm gonna voluntarily do this.
- Yeah. Yes.
There you go.
I feel like your posing was really good
and because you went up close, I'm like,
oh, maybe she's doing a lot of beauty.
- She kind of is, yeah.
- Okay.
(all murmuring)
- I'm chill, let's, I mean-
- Okay, maybe let's just see how looks.
- Okay, let's see how it looks.
- Your pose was good.
- Second or third?
- Oh sorry, fourth.
- Fourth.
- I think fourth.
- Do you guys agree with that?
- Yeah. How do y'all
feel about this so far?
- I don't need to overanalyze it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay.
(laid back music)
- Modeling. Is it what you,
you can live off of a year?
- Hell no.
- No.
- So everybody, mine? Yes, so.
- Whoa.
- Oh, if you said no back up.
- I can live off of.
- Okay, let's switch.
Let's switch, yeah, yeah.
- Can you live off of my money?
- No.
- Oh, but it also depends on your,
I guess your lifestyle.
- Oh yeah, that is true.
- Oh, so if you live, if
you live frugally or like-
- Or with your parents
- Or with your parents or like anything.
- Okay. Wait, then I should, okay.
It is sustainable, if you minus that.
- Do you feel comfortable like-
- Living? Yeah, do you feel comfortable?
- Like is you're like having
relatively happy with.
- All right, let's move back again.
(all laugh)
- Can everyone name
like the biggest brands
they've worked with?
- Christian Dior, Nike, Forever 21,
I'd have to go Tiffany's.
- Yeah. Instagram, Facebook,
Target, Adidas, Nike.
And then two this year for in Europe.
So I did Sinéad O'Dwyer Runway.
I was the first paraplegic model
in London Fashion week ever.
(all applaud)
- Based off that, I feel
like you guys should switch.
- Absolutely. Please.
- Yeah.
- Our biggest brands I've
worked with is Verizon.
Obviously Target, Amazon,
I've done some stuff
for Sephora, Tom Ford.
- Okay, I'm coming down.
- [Off Camera] Would you guys say
that the modeling
industry can sometimes be
exploitative of people.
- It's extremely exploitive.
(all chatter in agreement)
- When you think about it
like, we make good money.
- Yeah.
- But when you think about how much money
the brand makes off of you.
- Exactly.
- It's like, they're making money.
Like, they can pay you this.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Have either of you done
any travel commercial work?
- Oh, I have.
- You have?
- Yeah.
- That's like a huge thing.
- I can definitely say
I have not been flown
out of the country for
any commercial work.
- Okay, so swap.
- Same. Yeah, I think you should be first.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Okay. That's maybe guys.
- That's like three on the front.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I like that.
- [Off Camera] Could you guys
maybe speak a little bit about
how body type or ethnicity
comes into play with casting?
- Oh let's talk.
- Oh it definitely comes into play.
I've been fired for gaining
two inches on my hips.
I've had emails going like,
"Oh, you gained half an inch on your hips.
I need you to take this more seriously.
Consider it like an athletic competition."
I was pressured to lose more inches
even though I was already
naturally underweight.
Tried to get there and not
knowing what, you know,
the right steps were for wellness.
Thought it just meant like
eat less and work out more.
And I was just deteriorating
my body, actually,
reversing the goals that I wanted to reach
and just developed this eating disorder.
It was really, just a really
unhealthy relationship
with food and exercise.
After I got to a place where
I felt really confident in myself
I still wanted to go back
cuz I did enjoy modeling.
So I am gonna just be me.
I'm going to eat and I'm
going to be confident.
- I have like have had
the opposite problem
because I'm kind of in between sizes.
A lot of times people
think that I am plus size
and then I show up to
set and they're like,
"Ooh, you're not big enough."
- I still think Matt
should be first, honestly,
because like, Matt could
be a diversity hire
but you also have like
an all-American look.
It kind of sucks to say
but I feel like Asian men
are still not at the forefront.
We're not as popular or trending.
I definitely don't-
- Trending is a good word.
- Yeah, tending in a sense.
And modeling is trends.
It's all about trends, what's popular.
So I feel like Matt should
still be first honestly.
- I agree.
- I agree with that.
- For a lot of stuff.
- I do believe Jaelynn should be after him
because she's a woman and she books
really, really high brands
she can't talk about.
Ivan should be next to, in
between these two, I think
because you have to travel.
And they do not compensate for a lot.
- I'm not traveling if
you're not paying me.
I agree though.
I do agree but I am not
traveling if not paying for it.
- Okay cool.
- [Off Camera] Do you have
any last minute rearrangements
you want to make?
- I just started, I kind
of want to move down.
- Yeah, I think you should move down.
- Oh yeah you did just start.
- Where do you, where do
you do your groceries?
- Costco
- I shop at Trader Joe's.
I'd rather be second.
Y'all said don't move
so I'm gonna stay here.
- I shop at Whole Foods I'll move up.
- Okay, you know what?
- Yeah, that's fine.
- I love Trader Joe's.
(upbeat music)
- [Off Camera] In seventh we have Emily.
In sixth, Victoria.
In fifth, Monica.
- Oh we're doing good.
- Kinda, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Off Camera] In fourth, Gabby.
- Whoa. Oh okay.
(excited chatter)
- Kinda on it.
- Maybe we become agents.
- [Off Camera] In third, Ivan.
- What?
(excited chatter)
- [Off Camera] In second, Jaelynn.
(surprised chatter)
- I told you guys.
- Okay.
- [Off Camera] In first, Matthew.
- Nice. Yeah.
- Wow.
(all cheer and applaud)
- Yeah. So what I'm trying to change
and why I model is because
I'm forced to live off of SSI,
which is different than disability.
If you were a young person
born with a disability
or if you became disabled
before you could pay
into social security for five years,
you're forced to live
off of less than like,
$850 a month in the US.
Yeah, I'm not allowed to earn any money.
So I just do this for fun
and for my friends brands
and to also be like a
visibly chronically ill
and disabled person who's modeling.
Even if I made the most
amount of the people here
I would not be a able to survive
off of that with having to pay
for private health
insurance and caregiving.
- I'm including things before tax.
So I would say about 5K this
year, cuz I just started.
- I am gonna say 25 and that's because
I feel like I haven't booked
that many things this year.
- I'm 50 K this year.
- I'm at like 90 K this year
and that's mostly because
of a few blessings.
Companies that worked with me like a lot
and like one couple of big jobs
that really pushed me over the edge.
- This year I've made
probably 115 or 120 K
- Woo.
We tied, I'm also one 115.
- Oh hey.
- That's hilarious.
- Yeah, I put 110 for
the average on the thing.
- Oh shit, okay.
(laid back music)
- It was really difficult
cuz everyone is obviously
really beautiful and we
all have our own things
that make us all unique
and is the reason why we book.
- This is really giving me perspective in,
you know, pursuing this full-time.
- And I think it is important
for people to realize
that there are exploitations
in the modeling industry
and it's important to be educated about it
and like watch out for it.
But, at the end of the day
like, it pays great for what it is.
It's very enjoyable.
The pros outweigh the cons still.
- I'll hope you blow up off this video.
- Yes. Blow up.
- I'm gonna go follow her.
- Yes.
- I just like the clothes.
I'm like really about
clothes, if you can't tell.
- Just make sure you're
secure in who you are.
Don't try to fit in a box
that is not meant for you.
Just follow what's natural
and the right doors will open.